like what do people not understand about
what that is like to drop in on a 70 80
foot wave you know I think everything is
just turned up to a hundred in terms of
like sensory overload and you know the
greatest fear really comes from within
your own brain but like actually riding
the wave the speeds are insane I mean
when we're riding out at Nazareth I'm
easily doing 55 60 miles per hour but
you know until you're going down a
vertical wall that's like
getting close to 90 degrees at times you
know it's like a completely different
sensation there's a free-falling feeling
and it's like my first few ways I'm like
I just feel like I can barely stand on
my board and then usually by the end of
that session or the next day I'm like
okay like I've I've kind of found my
comfort zone again because at a certain
point riding a big wave going straight
can to me it gets boring if you're going
straight the whole time for you to say
like just to ride the wave is is boring
is like bananas